buildings are being destroyed animals
are dying and trees are not able to grow
all because of rain wait I thought we
needed this stuff well it's not just any
kind of rain this is acid rain wood
buildings really disintegrate how would
the acid affect our food supply and can
it burn your skin this is what if and
here's what would happen if it rained
acid if a super acid like carbureted can
disintegrate things instantly came
raining down from the sky it would
destroy everything in its path entire
buildings cars and even you but luckily
we won't be dealing with that instead
we'll have something known as acid rain
falling from the sky although its
effects won't work like carbon the end
result of acid rain will be much much
worse for everything it touches unlike
normal rain that is slightly acidic acid
rain contains high levels of nitric and
sulfuric acids this makes its acidity
level a pH of around 4 which is similar
to tomato juice acid rain doesn't occur
naturally it comes from humans polluting
chemicals and pollutants that are caused
from burning fossil fuels enter our
atmosphere there they mix with water and
oxygen to become acidic rain luckily a
little bit of acid rain doesn't cause
much damage we've already had instances
like this before but what would happen
if rain was always too acidic although
this situation isn't ideal you can at
least be happy with the fact that acid
rain won't affect you directly
meaning if acid rain touches your skin
it won't burn you but there are still
many ways that you can be indirectly
affected by the rain the main thing that
will suffer is the environment
acid rain can severely weaken and
eventually kill trees it penetrates the
ground draining valuable nutrients from
the soil some trees will have the waxy
coating on their leaves stripped away
leaving the tree unable to create energy
through photosynthesis what else will be
hurt besides the environment buildings
roads and other materials will slowly
degrade due to the rain with acid rain
these things will erode much faster than
they do now
entire cities will crumble over time due
to the acid rain after acid rain hits
the ground it will eventually end up in
our lakes rivers and oceans all this
acidity in the water will gravely harm
the fish that live in it some fish will
be able to survive better than others
but some such as shrimp and mussels
won't last long and if any fish are born
when the water is too acidic they'll
have a good chance of being born with
deformities and if just one species of
fish dies it can destroy an entire
ecosystem due to that fish missing from
the food chain over time all fish will
die due to their environment completely
changing they won't be able to adapt
quickly enough water sources all around
the world will become completely devoid
of life now I don't need to tell you
that this will seriously affect our food
supply fish are a major part of over 1
billion people's diets you'll have to
say goodbye to sushi and fish and chips
and how will acid rain affect you did
you seriously think that you were going
to get out of a what-if scenario
completely unscathed all the increased
sulfur dioxide that will be in the air
will cause you some severe lung problems
like asthma and bronchitis with our
trees slowly withering away our
infrastructure being destroyed and huge
parts of our food supply disappearing
the earth will become uninhabitable one
way we could stop this would be to jail
engineer the weather to act the way we'd
like it to
or you know maybe we could just stop
polluting and the issue would resolve
itself that's how we got into this
situation in the first place maybe we
could charge companies to pollute but
we'll leave that story for another what
if
[Music]